en el bicentenario de la muerte de
napoleón bonaparte el presidente manuel
macro en lo definió como una figura de
contrastes destacándolo como constructor
estratega y legislador pero también
criticando su restauración de la
esclavitud durante un homenaje el
mandatario depositó una corona de flores
en su memoria el primer presidente
francés que lo hace desde georges
pompidou quedó la fifa
netview para mí en fin napoleón es el
hombre que dio cuerpo a nuestra
organización política y administrativa
que dio forma a esta soberanía tiendas
que salía de la revolución assets
urgente datos no quiso usted la
abolición la figura del emperador sigue
siendo muy controvertida en francia y
muchos ciudadanos lo critican por su
totalitarismo y excesos en las guerras
que libró
el final de su vida fue miserable pero
es una de las más grandes figuras
políticas francesas entre todas las
reinas reyes y emperadores y videos y en
lo cual yo
otros lo recuerdan por su aporte
histórico al país como la introducción
del código civil que está entre una gran
figura política francesa y entre un
dictador porque aportó muchos grandes
logros como el código civil y otras
cosas
napoleón tomó el poder con un golpe de
estado en 1799 y extendió su dominio por
toda europa revocó la abolición de la
esclavitud en las colonias francesas y
retrocedió en los derechos de las
mujeres en 1821 murió en el exilio de la
isla de santa elena desterrado por los
británicos tras su derrota en waterloo